[Musique]
nous sommes à la pisciculture des villes
est en compagnie d'emmanuel coupant
bonjour bonjour et bienvenu merci vous
êtes le responsable donc de la
pisciculture
oui alors vous vous maintenez de me
donner une paire n'empêche il ya un saut
aider à passer ça exactement
moi je n'ai jamais déchets est-ce que
c'est compliqué c'est pas très compliqué
à la pisciculture de villette en
accueille de nombreux pêcheurs adultes
ou même enfants à partir de 3 ans qui
viennent découvrir la pêche
alors je vous ai confié une petite canne
à pêche très simple équipé d'un fils
d'un bouchon orange et au bout d'un
petit hameçon cette absence et le
crochet qui va attraper le poisson pour
commencer on décroche l'hameçon
dans ce petit pot vers il ya de la pâte
à pain il faut donc former des petites
boules pour faire des appâts et c'est
parti le bouchon orange doit être sur
l'eau et quand le bouchon cool il faut
ferrer c'est à dire tirer vers le haut
d'un coup sec et bravo et voilà et là on
a donc une truite arc en ciel donc c'est
une truite qui est âgé d'à peu près 12
13 mois elle fait 300 gr elle a des
belles nageoires bien développé ça fait
quinze minutes que je suis en train de
pêcher
alors au début c'est vrai que c'est
assez compliqué il faut prendre le coup
de main et puis finalement j'ai péché de
trois poissons ou alors que c'est déjà
pas mal
c'est super c'est un très bon début la
pisciculture et l'art d'élever les
poissons à la villette ce sont
essentiellement les truites arc en ciel
les truites fario et des saumons de
fontaine
là vous avez donc des bassins pour le
plus tôt les débutants mais finalement
il ya des bassins pour plusieurs niveaux
des étangs parce que arrivé à un moment
ça va trop vite ici donc on a un un lac
qui est juste derrière à une dizaine de
matches ici ou là les gens viennent avec
leur propre matériel parce qu'ils
s'équipent après même des enfants et ils
passent la demi journée ou la journée au
bord de l'eau alors là c'est la vraie
pêche siamap instantanément faut parfois
attendre une demi-heure avant qu est une
truite qui mordent par contre c'est plus
fin on va changer la part on va avoir un
film beaucoup plus fin que celui à mes
trois fois son pays je me dirige en
boutique pour les faire vider ce magasin
vend des produits du terroir mais aussi
détruite ou saumon fumé des terrines et
rillettes de poisson donc voilà vos
poissons et les fiches recettes qui vont
avec à terme la bobox nation merci voilà
moi je repars avec eux mais trois
poissons j'en ai eu pour 9 euros
et poissons compris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]